so uh you know blit he's the master
prankster around here yes so he put
together this whole deal on Ronnie to
convince him that Mike Pearlman was in a
plane accident and has Amnesia he's a
sick bastard dude geez that's sick uh
after I hung up with him that day I
realized that this there something got
to be wacky because it's it's blit you
know what I'm saying yeah and so I I
Google I went on Google and I googled
plan cra es on Long
Island and there's all kinds of plane
crashes right nothing listed for
Pearlman so Blitz messing with Ronnie
they even have a picture of Mike
Pearlman next to the wrecked
plane so anyway this is blit breaking
the news to Ronnie about this horrible
thing that happened to Mike Pearlman you
know I told you Pearlman was taking
Pilots lessons yeah he he crashed his
plane okay he's fine he just basically
has Amnesia which is the [__] up thing
this better not be any stick dude let me
tell you it's not see that see the
problem with you I can never [__]
believe you man yeah I know but this is
real where did this happen it happened
in Long Island I there a crazy picture
also send me the picture okay where is
he now he's at home now really you sent
him home like that the doctor thought
it'd be best for him to be at home given
the Amnesia really will you talk to him
yeah yeah so Ronnie goes this can't be
real the only guy he trusts is JD so he
Ronnie calls JD uhhuh JD's here blit
gets a hold of JD and says you better
not [__] up my bit now JD's caught in
the middle of this [__] bit because
JD loves Ronnie but yeah that was in my
office he had just came to me and said
okay I need you to uh pretend that prman
is has been in a plane crash blah blah
blah Ronnie calls him right there and
[__] I blit I told blit blit don't
get me involved I don't want to deal
with this please just I don't want to be
involved with this he [__] lied he
lied to you I did I felt listen to this
here's Ronnie and JD now with I can
never believe anything this [__] guy
tells apparently there was some plane
accident I guess he's flying or
something and yeah I saw a picture and
all that [__] you wanted me to get on
Zoom with some doctor [__] yeah the
doctor was no is this is that true or is
some phony
doctor dude I don't know I just blit
wanted me on the zoom with this doctor
and pear and if he's [__] with me
again as always I'm going to [__]
kill him I swear to God I just want to
say I felt like a hostage talking to
like someone trying to make things
normal and because blit was like
recording me standing there look at me
in the eye you put uh JD in a real hot
spot there there was no gun to his head
he could have said no yeah here's Ronnie
talking to Mike Pearlman who now has
Amnesia from a plane crash what's up I
don't know I'm [__] out of it dude so
what what are you up to man nothing just
[__]
relaxing yeah everybody needs to relax
once in a while who are you it's Ronnie
I don't know no Ronnie you're your old
Nemesis man I don't know it's it's it's
a tricky situation you're in you'll be
you know I don't know you it'll probably
take some time you'll be fine you know
you'll be back to work with us it's all
good man my [__] head is killing me
dude well you look good but I still want
my bagel back no matter what what Bagel
when you come out of this mess you're
going to give me my bagel back and
you're going to tell me how you took it
what are you talking about was all those
Bagel talk yeah you'll know you'll know
oh man I'm looking at you bro but I
don't even recognize you how could you
how could you not recognized his face
well like what we were friends prior to
this yeah yeah we were friends I'm
getting tired man I'm going to take a
nap it's all right you'll be fine I know
it's a lot it's a lot a lot of strain on
you we'll talk again promise we'll talk
again promise all right I'll talk to you
soon all right nice to meet you man all
right hang in there all right we'll go
to sleep now all right yes strong
remember that hey first of all what's
with Daniel Day Perman over there what
an actor I was like oh my God this is
the worst acting I've ever you could you
could feel the head injury when he was
talking I felt so bad doing this I mean
as funny as it was it it was like you
know when I was talking to him on Zoom I
had to minimize the screen of his face I
didn't want to look him in the face cuz
I couldn't I was going to start laughing
immediately but did you uh and when you
talked to him on Zoom you had to have
your head banded you know what I did
Howard I kind of channeled how I felt
when I got shot I remember laying in a
bed and kind of feeling really out of it
I just remember like you know it's was
like strenuous to talk at that point you
know I I asked him I asked him about
that I said do you remember getting shot
and he goes did you shoot
me Mike this might be your greatest role
yet did you feel bad for I felt horrible
he was so nice you know I I he's never
been I've never seen him this nice like
like I had to get into a plane crash him
to be nice to me but he was like you
know uh anytime you want to talk he's
like I'll talk to him every day if he
wants to talk he goes don't worry buddy
you're strong you got to get through
this I mean how nice are Ronnie to you
know spend time with Mike on Zoom
incredible incredible he's a great
Samaritan what I learned from blit and
you're a [__] [__] if you get
involved with him he will waste a lot of
your time but you know I also I gave
Ronnie a great experience he's going to
look back at this and laugh it was like
going to the Great Escape without
leaving the comfort of your own home it
was really created an experience created
an experience for
him